this is what's left of one of tortilla's
most historic cities hatai it's largely
in Ruins following two powerful
earthquakes and hundreds of Tremors on
Monday
more than 1 200 buildings have been
destroyed in the province
people spent the night sifting through
Rubble looking for signs of life
we heard him they're calling out asking
for help they're asked to be rescued we
cannot rescue them how can we rescue
them nobody has come since this morning
nobody we have nobody look around look
they had voices our children are in
there what can we do the building is
already partially collapsed this is
human life what can you do when you hear
calls for help there are no emergency
workers no soldiers nobody this is a
neglected place
[Music]
listening for any sign of survivors
these rescue teams in gaziantep call for
complete silos
moments later
foreign
operations are being carried out in
malate Dr bakar Adana and several other
locations across turkey
but the scale of Destruction is a
challenge for rescue teams several
airports were put out of service by the
quakes
along with some hospitals those still
operating are overcrowded the death toll
is rising and thousands of people are
injured or homeless
enabling Syria a similar situation we
are talking about a population that has
been a struggling to get access to all
the basic Services uh all the supply
lines are going through turkey and given
the situation just across the border
these supply lines are extremely weak uh
today and and they were yesterday so we
are trying to find suppliers who could
manage to find ways to get uh food and
and Equipment across the border the main
one for Humanity and Aid was closed by
valhawa and we were hoping that this
will reopen very soon
as in Turkey Rescuers in Syria are still
extracting survivors from under
collapsed buildings cheering any lucky
find such as this young boy in the town
of jandaris
both Damascus and Ankara say they need
International help and urgently Muhammad